the big organic reach right now is on
LinkedIn YouTube shorts and Tik Tok
Instagram is hard if you're posting on
Instagram it is hard too much Supply
against the demand so much of the young
demand went to Tik Tok more content was
made on Instagram yesterday than ever
before but the audience is fragmented
more than it was pre tiktock attention
is the number one asset hi hi hi great
to see you great to see you hi hi 37
joining here we have what 20 Hawks I
think s
yeah let's
call this amazing first of all let me
focus on everybody in the zoom since
I've got everybody in the room everybody
it's very great to see you hope
everybody's super well thank you all
many of you for uh the birthday wishes
um and I'm excited about this this
should be a lot of fun for all of you in
here it's also on the big screen as well
so um Dan when people from the zoom ask
questions that you're going to bring
them up or you going to bring them all
up on the grid or you're we going to
bring everyone yeah that's what I want
to do please do that for joining hang
Hawk 11 we're going to first start with
sidel Sidell thanks for joining us go
ahead and click the unmute welcome to
hang out Hawk session 11 your question
number one man well thanks for um having
me y'all it's great to see you guys um
so my name is sidel jidel and I'm
currently developing a social trading
platform so we're live in the App Store
we're Venture back USV dragonfly and
we're doing really really good with the
web 3 audience but we're trying to
figure out how to bring some of that
magic of you know collecting cards
trading them staking them playing them
to the web 2 masses so we're trying to
figure out how we can kind of position
ourselves in a way that appeals to web
two people that don't necessarily
understand those concepts of staking
ownership and creators Etc so Gary I
just wanted to know what you kind of
thought about that yeah y listen a
couple things one um this year with
hangout Hawks I'm really focused I to
said this to Daniel I want to really
like deliver on the energy of the
purpose of the token which is like
really do business one-on-one and
personal one-on-one obviously a lot of
the last couple years like what are you
g to do with the Hawks what's happening
after the hawk and by the way I'm
thrilled to do that but Daniel and I can
do that at Hawk as well we can do that
at the end as well but I want like just
to start off I really want to like
actually deliver on what I want to do
with this like this question so for
example no matter what anyone's doing
here this answer is going to work and I
want you to all to hear it whatever
Journey you're on first you can't hope
for Consumer
reality this is very important to
understand you can't Hope For What the
consumer does you need to understand
what the consumer does and make it for
them so brother to to answer your
question when I launched an e-commerce
website in
1996 you know I knew it was going to be
a while before all of you would buy
everything on the internet like like of
course I wanted people to buy wine
sooner but people made fun of me and
said like why would I buy one in the
internet I'll just go to the store that
was 90% of what people told me I'll just
go to the store so you can imagine you
know like people like staking there's be
web 2 and web 3 don't exist they're just
humans what I mean by that is like I
know how we all Define them but like
people that play
games kagachi or whatever that thing was
that was staking you like your egg was
brewing like the longer you had like
people understand the principles it
depends on how much friction you have
for people to do the thing right and
then more importantly for everyone here
how good are you at getting people to
know about the thing so if you think
about this think about how many people
we onboarded with we friends onto
ethereum that required marketing we did
lessons we made content we did blog
posts for a lot of you we were that
person for you for a lot of you and for
a lot of people we all know it like you
know and so you know I think what you
need to do is focus on two things
brother one is it just understandable
and is there any friction in how you're
doing it tactically you know uh I
mentioned something on the fanatic
stream that some of you might have
watched we're even thinking about like
there's so many people right now asking
how to buy a vfriend who even when we
send them all the stuff we have just
don't want to create a
metamask but they're ready right now to
buy like a $20,000 vend so as you can
imagine I'm like this is sucks like we
need to we need to figure this what had
a Marketplace go figure right so like
like like we what we a you got to think
about your friction right at the when I
launched wine library.com the friction
was people didn't even have
email like that's where I was sending
them their receipt they were like what's
email like I I know but but this but
this will make sense to a lot of you
because some of you know that AI is out
there but some many people in this room
have not really spent an hour playing
with chat GPT yet you know it's there
but you haven't like and that's how 97
was they heard about the worldwide web
but they hadn't bought anything on it
yet and you have unlimited friends who
have not bought an nft using blockchain
technology right so two things one are
you creating friction for them two is it
understandable and then three most of
all it's Universal for everyone here is
you've got to know how to
storytelling Instagram and Tik to the
world lives on these devices and you've
got to be able to story tell so you have
to create demand through creative
whether that's paid advertising or
organic preferably organic cuz that's
the world we now live in right like it's
super cool for all all of us
entrepreneurs you don't have to pay
unlimited ads if you get if you are the
best in the world at Tik Tok right now
if you are you will get unlimited people
to know about everything you want so
that's the f I I think to the web two
world just means consumers yeah you know
what I mean brother like you're just
talking about consumers so I think it's
about you're talk you have a marketing
question you know it's a marketing
question I agree I really think it comes
down for us the storytelling we've tried
to reduce the fiction by getting in the
App Store completely removing metam
correct that's huge to your point like
narrowing down that storytelling notice
where I went with it because once I
heard you say that I'm like okay he's
already got over that hump people do
know how to download an app oh by the
way when the iPhone came out day one
like that was the
friction like you know Twitter was
desktop when I started on it there was
no app you know and so like that was the
friction and that's why huge companies
were built Uber and instacart and
because that was the friction so yeah
it's it's a marketing story for you
brother cool than you got it and and and
the big organic reach right now is on
LinkedIn YouTube shorts and Tik Tock
Instagram is
hard if you're posting on Instagram it
is hard too much Supply against the
demand so much of the young demand went
to Tik Tok more content was made on
Instagram yesterday than ever
before but the audience is fragmented
more than it was pre- ticktock things
like that or is your audience even there
if you're selling B2B SAS products
linkedin's better than snap some of
those things as well that we have to
think
through awesome gonna hand the mic over
to Bryce Bryce thank you for joining
just make sure to click on mute you're
good to go awesome thanks guys Gary
thank you for your time always apprciate
you spending time with us brother are
you kidding me I'm pumped to be with all
of you quick background I am a first
marketing hire for a 75 plus year old
building products uh
distributor and I have a million and one
different angles that I can play I've
spent the first year and a half building
out infrastructure like brand guidelines
uh new website uh first ever CRM for the
company tons of big projects um two-part
kind of question one how do you oh you
want you H mute by accident something
happened how do I sorry about that no
worries um kind of a two-part question
here one how do you view or or create
overall marketing strategies I'm a onep
person Department right now um who are
you trying to reach in this company by
the way is it a B2B business yeah we
primarily work with contractors gc's
building uh professionals uh remodelers
right um so are you Bryce what did you
go to school for marketing no all
selftaught but through like it we I'll
tell you why I asked the brand
guidelines that like like you're going
about it very academic which doesn't
bother me that wasn't like a Raz even
though I was an F student everybody
knows it like I'm just trying to get
your framework like they had no
consistency as far as branding colors
logos any of that stuff why did you
gravitate towards that is actually my
question you need to Rally behind
something out in the public right there
needs to be a visual identity that
people associate with your brand right
but you're a you're not
Nike you had the win on relevance more
than brand positioning I spend a ton of
time on it I put that together it's like
a one sheater basically if that's what
you're asking it's more about the first
year how long have you been in about a
year and a half so those were just some
of the key initiatives I mean the CRM
was a huge thing integrating that with
our Erp software and Our IT department
on that building out the website by
myself and completely transferring that
over I just got first phase involved
with that I have seven eight phases 75
plus Pages yet to build out for that and
a content and an SEO strategy I'm trying
to figure out from a holistic picture
ramping up content by myself I don't
even I didn't even have a a functioning
website to send them to of course so I
had to get some of those pieces put into
of course overall picture how would you
approach that and then tactically as a
oneman department how do do I kind of
take the biggest and best fight out of
that
Apple um so I assume the organization is
a sales
organization right and so who are are
these individual
contractors so we we're a distributor so
yeah we're working with individual
contractors and Contracting businesses
roofers CER sighting contractors Etc and
you're selling and you're selling yeah I
get it and you're selling direct to
direct to them through the website or no
no we don't have an e-commerce aspect
yet so the website is informational that
leads to the phone call or the inquiry
it's the sale it's the lead gen sales
engine yep for now
um so a couple things first of
all uh where where if anywhere is the
content studio in the world and here's
what I mean not a studio you're
delivering Goods after they phone call
you to them right and then they are
working right they're doing their thing
the first thing I would do is play on
people's ego I would
create a program for contractors that
are like the gold standard contractors
that you are anointing as a wholesaler
these 12 to 20 guys and gals as epic at
their craft by being
chosen into the gold standard circle of
our distributor cuz we think you're the
best contractors we are to come with our
iPhones AKA I Bryce I'm going to come
with my
iPhone and we're going to actually film
you on
job and we're going to give you that
content and we're going to use that
content so what you the way you're going
to create besides SEO which is
absolutely going to be a monster for you
and you've called that out if you're
talking about the question directly that
you're asking me it is pretty crazy how
much you can get out of LinkedIn and
YouTube shorts because of search engine
on YouTube and because of the way
LinkedIn targeting works against
contractors and things of that nature
but you need content I think your
content studio is you picking 12 or 20
customers and flattering them that you
think they're good and going and filming
them for the day so that you can then
post- produce it for your
content solid so from an overall
standpoint figure out getting that whole
content engine up and running content
engine is everyone every single question
that every single person is about to ask
me is content engine at the lowest cost
possible
okay yeah it's the answer now there's a
lot of answers after that fine now you
filmed it now what like do you know how
to do a thumbnail the first three
seconds do you understand a LinkedIn
Carousel is PDF versus the do you
understand Facebook Facebook groups like
do you understand your content should
sent to a Facebook group because you can
create virality within it that then
sends to your website like there's a lot
more but like anything in life like
where the what's the Fe you know I don't
know if you know this but your back
issues are really your feet
feet right yep yeah it's a brain [__]
but it makes so much sense it's your
feet and so so just like that like just
like I talk a lot about parenting that's
pretty foundational right like like
so yes notice what I did and I did it
and went in detail because it's a unique
answer to your question but it might
have sparked stuff for people in here
thinking about making content for this
business like [__] Studio I got to hire
3D rocks uh-uh here's a way to do it for
free we're going to flatter the people
who already buy from us make them part
of this special club and and what we're
going to do is go and fil and we're
going to bring value we're going to film
oh by the way the iPhone is more
powerful than the camera dck the iPhone
today is more powerful than the camera
that drock used starting to film
me right so that's another low cost go
film and so it yeah that's exactly right
brother I'm trying to figure out how to
and by the way there's so much wild [__]
literally you doing fulfillment in your
Warehouse filming that and if you really
know how to ASMR that stuff and do some
other wild stuff they're just wild [__]
that none of us would believe in a
million years would work as business
development or marketing that
works there's somebody in your Warehouse
named Carl that's been here for 29 years
who if you just filmed every day is
actually famous and will drive your
whole business sure so it's thinking
about these angles that you haven't
thought about
before that drive down your cost of
creative at scale filming yourself every
day writing a book becomes the marketing
of the book I filmed me drawing every
single be friend I got it it's there for
the documentary one day hopefully and
this and that but like I could use it
for marketing right now like that' be a
good post for us right just watch me
draw a hangout Hawk like I don't know
like so you know that's what I'm
thinking about a lot so as the only
person in the marketing department
focusing only on content like don't
worry about the balance of everything
else that has to be taken care of just
try my best to allocate as much time as
possible to that I I think it's a mix
brother I think the way you know like to
your point like like you know you can
build on something that I said that I
felt that was fairly smart and you might
get smarter than me you might be like
wait a minute I'm just going to ask them
to film and we're going to Showcase them
now all of a sudden they're doing
everything you're just you're just
giving them the
cosign right so mean to take any more
time up no worries no no but what's
what's good about hangout Hawk and what
I really want to do this year is like I
want to go deep like I need my dream of
this was that one thing was said to you
that you took like these are things that
everyone can comp on like I'm a
restaurant I need marketing I'm like
film The Kitchen 24 hours a day instead
of having a day when you do
content especially it makes want to go
there 100% there's a story there I'm the
over to Jac there who's going to run a
question for the Hawks that are in the
conference room go for it Jac yeah guys
want to raise your hand we'll do in
person I saw your head first you want to
ask your question sure so um by the way
I know you guys and GS know each other
pretty well but not everyone knows
everyone so once again name and like
what you do a little bit that's good for
all of you oh we all know yeah fair
enough but some of the people I know I
know I know fair enough fine listen if
you feel good about it go ahead I need a
mic
Anthony masuchi hi Anthony on all the
socials like friendly Anthony not this
kind of
Anthony Anthony Zer Anthony exactly um
oh by the way I had a meeting today that
was a guy I met at vcon and through
Hawks it's a long story the short story
is something great is going to happen
basically because of you no because of
you guys like us it friends networking
no it's hang it's the best just throwing
that out there when it's at right it's
the best go ahead brother so I know
we're all excited for your new book yes
and I I'm writing a book and I wanted to
ask you two things
what like how much where did you have
the most fun writing the book for you
personally where was that and the other
thing
was how important it is to have the
audience before the book or does the
audience come later or Etc I'll answer
the second one both happen right there's
people that build big platforms that
write a book people buy it obviously
easier you know Rachel Ray back to food
you watch her on TV she writes a book
you're like hey and then there's people
like malcol glad well we never heard of
him he wrote a book it was [__] epic
it went viral by itself and then so both
of by me crush it made me big the book I
was getting going a little bit but I was
really in wine and yeah I got a couple
Keynotes and definitely that one keynote
Smurf it up like that that like one that
changed my career one talk but the book
was equally a big factor the book
organically did well I don't know if I
yeah actually it's really funny this new
book Because of its title so a couple of
people have seen it and now I've
announced it and like I've gotten very
aggressive reactions to it and I've
always thought books like a post on
social media the thumbnail titles matter
yeah and there's something about this
title that just resonates with people
from an Intrigue or I fully get it or
like [__] that's the thing so I think
yeah so I think I might have something
with this one it's funny it's been a
topic the last two days I'm like we
might have something with this one but
Tim Ferris tested all right 4H hour work
week he tested out on Google and crushed
Tim Paris would be an example of
somebody so the second answer is it
could go either way okay um the first
one my f so first of all when I write a
book it's all audio so you just I talk
it out into your phone and you know I
always laugh when I'm at book signings
and people are like man the book really
sounds like you
like like you know cuz normal humans who
write books H you know speak one way and
write a different way I can't write yeah
I that is the one medium that I really
like don't have so I talk it out so for
me I'm very passionate about bringing
value it's very important to me when you
sell something wine be friend it's and
you know some you know this one
obviously I think everybody knows I'm
thinking for in a very long way other
things like a bottle of wine like
empathy crushed I'm going to make this
very simple for everybody it was $40
wine for 20 bucks wasn't super hard to
win that game we had the leverages of
the relationships to get the grapes cuz
I had 30 years in the business and I had
a billion favors at my disposal and we
were just able to make $40 wine for 20
bucks and people tasted that like if you
really drink it enough you kind of knew
like definitely people that bought $15
wine that like Gary Vee and decided to
pay 20 for empathy definitely felt the
difference when you're drinking A50 $40
wine when you normally drink $15 wine um
same with this book like I'm like [__]
man I went so hard at this one so my
favorite part is I've never pushed
myself this far I feel if I'm being
honest with myself and it took me
writing this book to realize that what
I'm about to say I'm not sure I ever I
always talk about I give away my best
stuff and you guys have and gals have
been on the journey like I figure out
Tik Tok I'm loud and I want you to win
too but something about this one I think
I went like another inch like I'm a
human like maybe I don't you know it it
made me question like have I given
everybody 100% no wait a minute I've
given everybody
95% there's always been something I held
back maybe I didn't fully know if I was
right yet maybe I'm just a normal human
being I was like wait I can't give away
every every I it it really made question
cuz this one's 98% and I feel it and my
publisher wrote me a she's been with me
in every book she wrote me a Banana's
feedback on it so my favorite part is I
think I went further I'm I'm about to
find out did you like talk talk while
you were walking did you have a favorite
place so ROV who we should actually
bring in here you get to meet him like
he's been on my team he's been doing a
lot of my LinkedIn stuff with Mackenzie
and like he like put together a lot of
structure there's I'm going to give a
big shout out to vayer media in this one
I had a lot of people from the agency
like help me get get it further along
then then I get asked 8,000 questions
and I answer we turn that into statement
form instead of question form then we in
some capacity yeah then we read it yeah
I mean I do like the opening rant which
is like like the book really like from a
like the book is like a philosophical
book for the first 25 50 pages and that
becomes a textbook to get you to do it
like first I'm like here's what's the
[__] is happening right even like just
what earlier just happened like I felt
great about what just happened where I
was like friends drive down the cost of
creative but do it in a way that like is
different than you're thinking about it
that doesn't mean hire somebody
obviously AI will have a big play in
this in the future in a massive way but
then everyone's going to use it which
means it becomes commoditized so then
what's your element out of it prompt
engineering there's a lot that's coming
so I always tell my clients if you can't
WR you can talk just Andy
Andy the next question we have a couple
hands up here on stage it's getting
bigger amazing bottom G I'm going to
pass the mic over to you if you can just
go ahead and click unmute if you got a
question for Gary at the team hear me
yes sir hi what's up what's up brother
how are you I'm good let me tell you
first my social media success I need to
tell you is connected to your content
you always put out so it's so dope that
you always bring the value you were just
talking about thank you
brother um I recently like last year
blew up with these I mean I look similar
to this Andrew Tate these dancing videos
right yes kind of situation yes
and I'm a music artist and a former show
dancer singer and stuff and I want to
translate that a little bit more into
the music and the entertainment stuff I
want to do my own shows and stuff and
I'm known in this let's say Mana sphere
in a way
like known let's say and I would say
that U at the end of the day you know I
do this kind of you know my little
dances and stuff so it's
like considered very gay but the moment
I speak about that I'm actually gay it's
like a problem so I'm in a weird I'm
known in a weird space and I feel I
should I don't know if I should change
the target group or like find a way to
expand in a different way you know yeah
I'm listening I'm listening look I think
first of all your permission for all of
us in any shape or form whether you look
the part of like or you are it or you're
not it gender race sexual orientation
religion interests we as humans have the
ability to expand the base by
communicating right like a very big
thing that happened in my career that I
want all of you to hear back to value
for all of you is I was the wine guy I
was on Conan O'Brien and Good Morning
America and like I was the wine guy and
I I wanted to like you know my life was
going through a transition I knew that I
was going to start this company and like
my brother was in college and I wanted
to start another company and then I also
at that point in my life knew oh wait a
minute I'm a marketing business guy who
also loves wine yes but like I I
definitely associated with myself as a
businessman more than a wine expert and
so I started making business content
right and brother what happened was
everyone's like what are you
doing what I don't think people
understand is we have permission do
whatever we
want and so I think the question becomes
what would you like to happen to I mean
I'm highlighting the fact that I'm a
singer I sing more in my content and no
no no I love this I'm I'm following very
along let me just jump in because I
think I want to get to the punch line
because I want to get there as many as
possible I assume you want to be as
commercially successful singer as you
humanly can yes yes then you need to
sing like and and you need to keep doing
the things that are getting you
attention and you need to keep doing
things that might get you attention
right you see Andrew Tate happening look
obviously you I don't think I'm sorry
it's not working his username is bottom
G because Andrew top G like like you you
figured out you you figured out your
thing but but like me right think about
how confusing I am as a Creator to the
world and I continue to be one post I
might post about V friends and you know
this you know what's going on with
friends and you're into it but a lot of
my audience is like I don't care I don't
like that nft thing and then the next
post I'm posting about the New York Jets
score and I'm sad and and like right and
that's the post and like for a lot of
people that are like following me
because they're a Fortune 500 CEO trying
to get a business Insight they're like
this is silly and I'm not even sure I
want to take this guy serious because
that's not and then the next post I'm
posting about like here's a hack on
Instagram and a lot of you like that
because everybody could get value from
that and so I'm doing a lot of I'm in
the and business
and you're asking me an or
question what I can definitely tell you
is every third post that you put out you
need to
sing fair enough makes sense it makes
sense
right no no it's funny I appreciate what
you're doing right now because this has
really worked for a lot of people I
understand what you're asking and it's
happening to
everyone right like when I break it down
this simply it seems so like silly in
common sense but everyone's so conscious
subcons iously or consciously stuck on
the algorithm and how to grow they
forgot why they're even trying to
grow period yeah this happens with a lot
of Attractive people there's a lot of
people that have shown their body both
boys and girls to build their audience
but that's not what their passion is
that's just how they get a lot of likes
they want to talk about cooking or they
want to talk about their car collection
or they want to talk about clo clothing
but the first time they post something
like that it gets nine views but if they
go [__] all like Thy they'll get 40
million and they're sad and they're
stuck and I keep saying like what are
you doing like what are th those those
Impressions aren't worth anything if
it's not what you're
doing but it can be and you can do that
to Garner the intention and you've just
got to be and the only thing holding
back people from doing it because it's
so logical is their own self-esteem
issues of this post didn't do as well or
it's going to [__] up the algorithm it's
all fear-based so bottom do them all so
like a
combo highlight more the singing still
still do the things what gives me the
attention let's say the and you know
this and and that attention is only
going to last for a little while because
it's a moment in time and it es and
flows and then a third thing try new
[__] do you
cook no good me neither do you do you
like like the third like add a third
thing and a fourth thing garage sales
wine the
Jets mindset blueberries be friends
Vayner media Vayner Sports basketball
game like like
things and and and and and you know but
stay in the core you know yes the you
find something that works don't give
that up unless it's completely killing
you inside keep doing it but and but
what's holding people back is you do
your bottom G skit or whatever you're
doing and it gets 100,000 views you go
and do a song and you sing and it gets
49 views like [__] that suck to me I'm
like no no no that's right because oh by
the way to remind you you just need one
right person to hear you sing true
yeah thank you great go I think honestly
I think that's again why I'm sitting on
some of these today because I think some
of this stuff is universal like you're
trying to build your Law Firm or your
real estate practice or this but maybe
your golf content is helping you sell
your real estate stuff maybe your AI
observations leads to you selling your
book maybe your parenting advice helps
you sell your like like I you know I say
this a lot I know a lot of you have
heard this from me watch what I do not
what I say I'm showing a lot of and on
top of that on top of everything else I
do another thing that [__] everybody up
on the reverse I keep my private life
private on top of all that what most
people go to to get likes their baby
their person relationships like you know
I keep it tight so you're in control you
oh Gary I don't want to do this I don't
want to show my kids don't show your
kids
is that the same thing if you're
building a company page as well do you
show a bunch of different things or if
you're doing a a company Instagram do
you stay focused on what the company
does no a bunch of different things
you're the the the secretary of the
company The Office television show
should be in play for all your
businesses because it's you you got it
I'm glad you picked up on that the funny
banter between you and your employees
might just be why people even know that
you sell
XYZ it's this game of and like if
somebody said bad news you got to write
a book right now on top of the book you
just wrote I'm like [__] it I'll write
an because I've been in on it like
everyone's [__] up with or awesome
bottom G thanks for the question we have
folks in chat asking for your handle so
if you want to share it out here for the
local thing on Hawks that's awesome I'm
GNA hand the mic over to Rarity Dale
Rarity Dale go ahead and click mute
thanks for joining us here early Matty
Mayo your goatee is looking good today
bro yeah hey thanks for having me on I
appreciate it you got it I got this from
Mo since I was in his Discord so I love
it to be able to come here do to him
good to see part of that so um two
questions real quick one uh first
question is what's the single piece of
advice somebody gave you that just stuck
with you forever that's been the most
important it's when my dad told me my
word was Bond I was so Gift of Gab I was
a kid I just wanted to sell everything
he just like it it was in me but like
like I was very intimidated by my dad
and he was he's just very black and
white and very like very and I was very
affected by that in a positive way I'm
incredibly
gray and that really helped me and it
like it was it was at the right time I
was 14 it was it was the right time and
it really like I I think it really
impact you guys know how much love I
give my mom like but like that was huge
like I think when people want to think
I'm a bad version of who I am like I
think that guy if I had terrible
parenting could have been affected by
that like it was really good advice at a
really important time in my life and I'm
really grateful for
it thanks for that um the second one is
uh I own a I own a merchant payments uh
payment processing business so we're in
ISO so you know it's it's mostly viewed
as a commodity for most part commodity
service y so besides our local client
base that we can get FaceTime with and
show them some love and care um how what
do you think that I could do to try to
change the Paradigm of the clients that
are in the rest of the United States
besides a local market so they don't
view me as a commodity versus um deeper
relationship become become become Flow
from
Progressive Insurance is a commodity
which is why Jake from State Farm Flo
and the Geico lizards
exist so back to your point in the
beginning of uh content questions going
to be answered by content brand is
everything yep there is nothing El it's
how humans make every
decision makes sense yeah so like to
your point for some of us in this room
you'll feel comfortable to be in front
of the camera good news you don't have
to just like I don't have to share my
personal life you do not have to be in
front of a camera but if I'm you Dale I
create a
mascot like look what I'm doing with be
friends this is the extension of me like
empathy El like I need to scale my
message for my own enjoyment I'm aware
that not every everyone's going to like
or listen to me it's not how the world
works so I'm going from being Hulk Hogan
to Vince McMahon I'm gonna make a lot of
characters now I'm on a mission I'm
still doing me and right but we're doing
a lot of work over these next you know
even look at how many people saw the uh
Alpha story on resourceful Robin on
Fanatics live anybody raise your hands
if you saw the card break two three four
I have a pixel no love for me so
so you know you guys saw that like like
even me going further to why I drew the
resourceful Robin like you know I have
no idea what how affected or not
affected but watching decisive duck rare
robot when that song came out all of a
sudden like just like storytelling
connective points why you know and so um
yeah Dale everything's a
commodity like like everything ends up
being a commodity like it's so hard to
not be a commodity
and so like all of it becomes brand like
like what the [__] like everybody can
make this for $9 or whatever the [__] it
actually costs to make at scale d d da
we all understand so it's all commodity
you need to create a brand and you and
if you could do it as a human being
that's epic cuz that's what you're doing
locally it's you the human you're
shaking hands kissing babies like high
touch warmth scaling through content
whether it's you or something or or
something that people can attach to
do you know why people's a lot of
companies are there are called ABC
delivery or laundry it was because the
Yellow
Pages right you would show up first but
now that's bad because it's a
commoditized brand right and so like
brand have a Live question
okay hi stany Beck I'm a luxury realtor
but I have a new business that I'm going
to launch and so this is more of a nuts
and bolts question for you um most
people people want to eat healthy and
make healthy food choices to be
healthier however many of the choices
suck and they taste bad and so I'm going
to use my superpowers of culinary uh
good flavors and things that I do when I
cook uh my superpowers for good and
create some uh spices that you add to
other products there's nothing like it
right now and I just learned my good
Hawk buddy Fernando has a packaging
company so I love it you can help I love
it so I'm wondering if you have some
companies you can recommend that would
do
organic uh non GMO vegan spices because
I need the packaging or the the co-
packing like you need the creation the
creation of my mixes and they would be
added in single packet yeah send me an
email okay get you take the email I need
to make a note I need to speak to I need
to introduce her to Gareth I'll take
care of the rest yes I have somebody in
mind okay it's not being done and I
think it could be very helpful for
people and exciting I'll sample everyone
and are you going to sell it direct to
Consumer at first or what's your plan my
plan would be to sell it direct to
Consumer through if we could do Drop
Shipping through
Shopify because then it' be very easy we
could do it in bulk be very easy to have
it pre-made and then these choices can
be vegan it's not done widely in
restaurants most soups are with cream it
could be with with coconut milk very
easy for them just to add packages it
can be done at home the videos I've
created minutes long um it can be added
to both yogurt or are you making food
content now yet uh no what I do uh is it
would be like if you make a smoothie
right now you can make vanilla chocolate
strawberry and everyone has a million
choices and they have their favorite
brand so for one of mine you take your
van vanilla you take a scoop of pumpkin
for instant to get your fiber and then
you put in my spice package and now
you've got a pumpkin pie smoothie you
can look forward to for breakfast that I
understand are you the human you yes
making any food content yet now uh I've
just done a few videos myself just in
general in general but they're not going
anywhere yet because that's that's what
I would like you to make unlimited
amounts yes back to his question what
you would be doing in that environment
that becomes the Rachel Ray version the
more you can start making content now
about your entire point of view on food
period yes clean vegan you know
grass-fed versus grass finish all this
stuff like you the more you can start
building now right you don't need to
wait to make content okay you should go
eat something outside now and make
content like you should start making
content as early as possible back to
book if the content you're posting is
you writing the book along the way
that's a very good formula so if you
wait if you wait a year cuz this is
going to take a year formula packaging
it's going to take you time okay like in
that year seven months nine months if
you go super fast it would have been
nice if you posted two to three Tik Tok
and Instagram and YouTube shorts a day
about food which gave you a base by the
time you launch this versus a cold start
99% of consumer package good products
fail okay so you're walking into a 99%
failure rate okay one of the ways to
mitigate that is to start building
Community now okay you don't need to
make it about your stuff right you could
make it about just food yeah okay like
you could you could F I mean especially
when you're in New York like there's so
many good options like you should start
doing that now okay great good start
tonight okay we do it thank you awesome
we're going to go back in here just
because we know a lot of folks are
virtual aren't with you right now to
spend time so I'm going to hand the mic
uh over here to pedor thank you for
joining us just go ahead and click
unmute okay and Daniel you're in the
you're in the comments right normally
I'm in the comments but something yeah
cool go ahead brother thanks Gary happy
birthday bro first of all thank you my
brother how are you good man good hey um
two really quick things one I'm sitting
in the business I asked you a question
about back last summer about how to
start and uh we have blown up by the way
proud of you bro so thank you very much
that's awesome bro proud of you um thank
you brother uh my my my next question is
actually the more important one and I'll
try to make it as quick as I can but
well the first one was a
statement I'm just I'm just having fun
with you gun okay okay
um uh I really want to see kind of go
back to the whole web 3 yeah um ethos of
things um so kind of the environment
we're in right with web 3 it's kind of
become of a a a weird place to navigate
from a business standpoint um nothing to
do with this business but um I know
she's in the room right now laptop Laura
and I we teamed up a while ago to to use
IP wres from the nft projects from 2001
um that that aligned it we had the book
duck buddies I'm looking at it yeah and
uh and well stay tuned for the next one
because you said titles matter the next
one is the horny Yeti so you'll love
that one
um but uh but we were're really
committed to to use this project in the
web 3 world like that's why we wanted to
go into it not only from the IP right
standpoint
um value to our readers because it's
it's a hard industry like kids book like
will jump into like a million people
pool right it's a tough one I'm about to
find out in we can't do back what we did
two years ago like here's a bunch of
tokens here's a bunch of nfts and here's
ownership blah blah blah how would you
good news I just want every this is
important based on the energy of the
room neither can people that do DTC
after iOS 145 update took away
cooking neither could people that were
first result on Yahoo when Google became
the primary search engine neither could
people that run television commercials
perfectly but now nobody watches them
and they have no idea how to do social
media content like it's very import like
there's something going on in the web 3
world that they're like oh now there's a
stigma around nft and like like I'm like
that happens every day in business all
the time there's always e and
flow so I just want to ground that first
it's not like and more
importantly this is what like like
social media took 15 years for like the
main world to be like okay this is a
thing
like all I did was be in rooms like this
in 2006 7 8 9 10 11 12 13 and people
like when are they going to take
Facebook serious I'm like one day you
know now that being said this is more
internet
2001 because the crash of the internet
stocks on Wall Street in 2000 gave the
internet a stigma nfts have a stigma
because of the up and down but that like
I don't know I like literally nothing in
my brain has changed about how I see all
this and like you all know this because
in the height of all the prices I made
videos saying 99% of these are going to
zero and and all the time I said this is
30 40 years now I myself got caught up
in the excitement of things of that
nature and I understand that but like
the macro thing the same like the block
as a matter of fact the advancements of
AI over the last year and how fast it's
happening and how much deep fake video
is literally on the presus of being
everywhere the blockchain is going to be
the most talked about technology it's
going to be it's going to verify all
information I am not going to post one
thing on the internet ever in 2026 which
is two minutes from now until I post it
on my block on the blockchain to show
that I posted it and so when you watch
it you be like did Gary post this or
somebody like like and with the rise of
how because everyone's gonna be scared
fuckless about AI once they really see
do you understand how if we wake up
every day and 80% of the videos we see
on the internet are fake how fast this
going to turn this is going to be one of
those things it's going to you're going
to wake you're going to wake up and it's
just going to be like everywhere it's
already happened it's not zero right now
it's not zero ESPN reported something
about Dame Lillard that was a deep fake
that already happened they already had a
resend it it got a little bit of
headline in the weekend on was it right
so like like the writer strike and actor
strike took a while because of this [__]
like there's a lot going on so
anyway to answer a question brother
first I just want everybody to know if
you like the blockchain good news it's
not going anywhere right if you like
nfts good news they're not going
anywhere 99.9% of nfts are not going to
be collectible because the people can't
create demand 99% of sports cards aren't
valuable 99% of art is not valuable 99%
of comic books are not valuable 99% of
sneakers are not collected watches
cars that was the part that everybody
got confused with nfts aren't Beanie
Babies nfts are stuffed animals stuffed
animals do great
mhm squish BS are hot right now but it's
an individual project within a framework
nfts is the
framework got it so to answer your
question you got to weather the
brandstorm like or not do it I don't
know you know what I mean like we're
committed to doing it that's we could
have dumped the web ID a long time ago
we just wanted to make sure that yeah I
mean do and there's so much cool [__]
going on in web 3 right now like the
like technology advanc
it's getting better and better and more
interesting and it's going to be easier
for users and it's so cool but yes I'm
aware of the brand positioning of nfts I
promise you I'm
aware awesome thank youor appreciate it
one more one more virtual then we're g
to go in person I'm gonna hand the mic
to Benny he was next up with the hand
raised thank you Benny for coming Benny
Benny gets I feel like Benny gets too
much air time
right hey it's called getting attention
but here's the here's the real deal I
need help make movie okay
and I know it's about Robin Hood the
artist the guy that you wor his hat you
know you remember this story I do
remember that kid down in Miami so after
during so I know hold on I want to make
sure the team in here knows so there's
an artist I met in New York now he's in
New York now I met him at Art bosle I
wore his hat Benny got it was good
things happened with which is just like
surreal and like he came from very
challenging circumstances got some
momentum going go ahead just trying to
get a little framework you can create
more went out to his van after I met him
at that ladies event that where we
talked to him at and I bought all of his
artwork in his van well I had no way to
get it home right so I live in
Pittsburgh I said if you drive to my
house in Pittsburgh I'll pay you the
rest of the money and then and that's it
so he came to Pittsburgh fell in love
with him even more heard his story um
ended up feeling like compelled to like
drive the rest of the way home with him
I got in this hoopy Minivan and drove to
Brooklyn with them I interviewed his
family I interviewed him I saw where all
of his art is I saw all the stories of
his art Anthony who's sitting right next
to you has been part of this Jay Jay Dev
my media guy he's got all the footage
that I recorded um and we were thinking
about this is before the announcement at
Deon in La I was thinking about trying
to figure out how to make a documentary
with my own media team you should on
like this guy's story about his story
about Art Basel you should first and
foremost 1,000% put out a mini doc on
YouTube like a or a Vimeo like a 5 seven
minute like call it half trailer half
mini do just play a little bit okay but
keep going and then I was thinking well
then when you announced that Von's going
to be on La and you know I love a good
satellite event and the Hawks like a
satellite event I would love to do a
production where it's like this movie
presented by like the hangout Hawks you
know maybe if we can get Vayner watt you
know involved with it a little bit I was
going to reach out to your partner on
that I know it's probably a long shot my
body languages I literally just had a
meeting with him three hours ago where
he's like all hold on a second and then
I remember who
I remember I remember who one of your
first speakers were at the first eon of
Minneapolis it was Spike Lee the famous
Brooklyn director heard of and this guy
grows up Robin Hood is in the hood of
Brooklyn I'm talking in the hood and I
just think that there's this weird thing
that's Brewing right here and again I'm
just Betty Fisher like I'm a roofing
contractor like I'm not a filmmaker yet
um but I'm really passionate about this
project and I want to know the next
steps I like the mini do idea well a
couple things I do think you put out the
mini do because I think the world is
about um executing or
asking I'm a big fan of executing cuz
asking is hard right like if you think
about your long- winded sentence there
was like four asks in there no I'm not
asking but but you are but you are which
you know I love you like like you are
ask help right now what I'm doing ask no
no no listen I'm trying to I'm trying to
really help you I think what I like
about the mini do is it puts you in the
leverage of it coming to you versus you
having to ask right by the way you know
this Benny you know I have a lot of love
for you like I could send an email to
Spike Lee for you and be like here you
go but like that's like and I can text
him and call him and see him at a Nicks
game be like yo check that email but
like you like that happens to be 40,000
times a day on the other side and like
0.001 of those things happen right um
like mini do is coming I'm just going to
let you know we already have an in
production mini Do's coming on the next
hangout hot call I'd love to show it to
you right like fine I think we'll
probably set that up separate on your
ask I'll watch it because I don't want
to eat up into the time of the rest of
the Hawks and the limited time that we
have in these things but I would say
make the content you're one Tik Tock
away of one scene that's been captured
from getting an email from WME agent
being like
yo we want to talk to you about this and
now you have Hollywood representation
you can make a movie it happens all the
time thatt right that's right I think I
think it would be I think it would be
awesome because it would culminate art
it would culminate entrepreneurs
Journeys it would culminate vcon vriends
like the whole thing I think it would be
a great I think it would be a great
piece so I'm gonna get I'm gonna get
busy working on that project I'm rooting
for you heavy thank you thank you Benny
I'm G to pass the mic back over there
for on site for Q&A cool um hey everyone
hey Gary Mark cerniglia um I own a
marketing agency and um me too I've
heard I've heard um so I'm actually
working on a new business idea that I
want to give you the The Cliff Notes
version of real quick and then I'd love
to hear your thoughts both obviously in
a way it would help me but also in any
any thoughts that might help the room so
um I'm going to work on a new business
model where instead of providing
marketing services to people I'm going
to provide marketing staff like
marketing assistant yeah makes sense but
what I'm going to do that's a little bit
unique is I'm going to have a fractional
model where they could have full-time or
part-time but the real thing that's
going to make it different from any like
Staffing model is we're going to provide
ongoing support important training to
that staff right and then that really
Blends well with the evolution of AI
because part of that ongoing training
will be AI training great so it's this
kind of hybrid model supported by an
agency right um I think I'm just kind of
curious to know your thoughts I think
the one challenge we're going to face is
we're going to solve a need people have
in a way that has not been proposed to
them yet that's right right and so just
figuring out that messaging and just
also any other thoughts you have or
questions you have I would I would
produce a lot of content on LinkedIn of
why you believe this to be true like
literally here's what I see here's why
this works over and over and over and I
would like to me you're going to get a
lot of nose because you're solving it in
a different way similar to you know so
many things that we've done at Vayner um
but I I think you're going to find a lot
of traction in small businesses and
small businesses are not corporations
right my dad doesn't give a [__] of how
it's supposed to be done he just wants
wants to know how much and so if you're
like it's 1,800 bucks a month he'll be
like what about a, and then you'll
settle at400 and then you're good I
think if you were working with Pepsi or
like the companies I am small business
yeah I think you I think you just focus
on price small business is the easiest
small businesses are like guys they're
easy small business you just walk in and
say cheap well and they know they and
they're like what you know what I mean
they're like what I need you know like
like going to be able to win on price
I'm being serious I'm making some jokes
a little ha it's nice to be together
you're going to win on price yeah I
don't think you're going to get that
much friction if you got to win on price
with small business yeah and well one of
the things I've been pretty good at is
is I've been growing my own team through
through hiring some staff like it's in
Mexico South America and so I think part
of this business model is going to be
we're going to be able to you're going
to pay for a third of what somebody
costs how many people on team Gary off
the top of your head here yeah no no
team
gary7 and how many of them live in
places like Mexico and Poland
and yeah I get it yeah no exactly but
just I think it's getting the market to
get it y right I got to go thank you
thank you everybody thanks Gary I assume
I'll see some of you soon right yeah
[Music]
[Applause]
awesome